appreciate y'all watching but listen our
partners at Blue chew they got you
handled fellas and Etc whatever you are
they got it if you got a dick Bluetooth
is for you because they will make sure
your dick performs at all time levels I
mean like LeBron his first three seasons
with the heat type levels I mean your
wife will thank you for it everybody
will thank you for it [ __ ] even if you
just take a blue chew and jerk your dick
it's a it's a stronger jerk I swear to
God stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure you're
gonna be beating your dick like a stole
something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg right now and you're gonna
get your first month free and this is
the great thing about Bluetooth the same
active ingredients as Viagra and scialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discrete
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
think me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the Bluetooth he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview how different
is um
trying to get into the movie and like a
TV game oh no it's a learning curve
because you know um like I didn't grow
up having like you know like a mentor to
kind of like you know guide me in the
film World
um or even in the directing world so it
was a lot of like first times for me and
I was a lot of trial and error
um but I'm very grateful I had those
experiences because they made me who I
am today but um yeah the Hollywood
system is just a totally different game
and it's really about you know learning
it's not just about oh you can make a
visually compelling music video it's
like can you tell a story yeah yeah I
mean can you you know keep an audience
engaged and that's kind of what I'm
learning now so I've been reading a lot
of books you know like there's a really
good one called uh you know making
movies by Cindy lament that I just
finished and just trying to connect and
you know surround my circle with more
people who do movies rather than just
people who do music you know
if you after your first movie I think of
this movie up here belly Hype Williams
directed it 100 and then he stopped
directing movies we'll see but that
movie visually was so [ __ ] crazy now
the storyline was kind of [ __ ] it's to
me the best worst movie ever but I just
like wish you would have kept going yeah
but sometimes with the Hollywood system
and that's why it's like it's so it's so
important to always keep going and keep
thriving because you know the first
movie who knows you might it might not
do good it might on paper look bad but
everyone knows and especially in hip-hop
that belly's a classic it's a classic I
mean like how many times in music videos
you see the treatment reference to
walking in of DMX 100 you got me and
it's just like and I think that movie
made more impact than noise at the box
office no for sure and I think like it
was definitely a DVD win yeah but they
sold so many [ __ ] DBS my Studios
don't see that you know they're gonna be
like all right how much did you make
opening week right oh snap we spent all
this money and we didn't make that back
or we only made that back in a little
bit now this don't make no sense you
know we rather shoot uh we rather do I
don't know a b flying around the you
know I was in this area are you to the
point now that like if you're like okay
I want to do a TV show based on my life
I can just bankroll that myself and then
shop it around to a distributor yeah and
it's funny because I came in that in the
music space like being that way like oh
if I believe in Russ I'm gonna put my
own money up and shoot a video for him
or if I believe in this artist I'm gonna
put my money up or if little baby gives
me 10K I'm gonna put an extra 5K to make
it even better you got me and that's
kind of how I flipped it but in the
movie world you start realizing it's not
just about the money it's also about the
Partnerships and the distribution of the
people who you're partnering with and so
like I I had a TV series and I was going
to shoot the pilot and I was like yo I'm
gonna spend my own money but then you
know I had some you know some people
some OG's be like yo you don't got to do
that we can find money and we can find
the right Partners strategically so when
the movie comes out we all bring assets
to it and it's just not you putting it
out on Instagram and being like buy my
movie you know because it'll probably
fail you know that's what I was gonna
say because I'm not sure like I'm not
super hip to the to that side of the
entertainment business but to me it
feels a little and I'm probably wrong
but it feels like a little similar to
like if you're an independent filmmaker
I guess kind of like a record deal like
if you have a something that you believe
in and you can produce it yourself you
can't wait and that's why I decided to
um and while my company and the reason
it's called Blaine squares because you
know you really start at a blank slate
and I know that you got to fill it in
yourself and that's kind of why I call
the company that and yeah so I decided
to move my best friends um to my
production company I decided to own my
own equipment so I bought cameras you
know Lexus and lenses and tripods and
monitors I started my own Post House you
know that does editing and color
correcting and VFX and I open up all
these companies simultaneously as my
business and production company were
growing and that's why now I'm able to
be self-sufficient so now if I want to
shoot a short film all right maybe I
just have to pay the actors and some
crew you know I don't have to pay the
camera I don't have all that in-house
and I kind of just took it off the
toilet paper model you know yeah back in
like 2015 I think I saw like an article
where he's like he's developing
something crazy extravagant and I was
like I can do that too but at a smaller
scale and I just started instead of
taking the money that I made for music
videos and put it in my pocket or spend
out at the club I was like let me buy a
camera let me buy this and now I still
rent my gear out and it's like a side
hustle you know yeah so you'll yeah not
only are you shooting the [ __ ] but if
somebody needs cameras your company will
ran out gear honestly like and it's
funny like a lot of directors
um you know in the music video world
like we edit their videos and they don't
even know it's my company you got me and
it's just like you know it's just like I
try to get a bag everywhere yeah I mean
it's all left to everybody but it's just
funny because you know I think sometimes
as music video directors you know you
feel like there's only one spot which
that's not true we can all win and it's
just like and that's kind of why like
even being on this platform I want to
say that because I think what we got to
do a better job of is you know
developing the community because you
know music video directors it's like
different than any other art form we get
billions of views but we don't get a
percentage of videos yeah I mean like we
don't get to know part of the YouTube ad
we don't get another thing like you get
a one time for a photo or like a a movie
so it's like we get a one-time fee and
yeah as much as it's nice that one time
fee especially if you're a bigger
director
um yeah that doesn't that's that's not
passive income thank God I have other
companies that do that but this like you
know and I think that's what we have to
come together and stick together to make
a change because I feel like you know um
I think over like as a director I think
I have over like 20 billion views that's
great just to think about that you know